well I am here with the co-author Double
Down TV voice it's all the while I'm
here with John Heilemann you wrote uh
Game Change back in 2009-10 well wrote
in 2000 I came out in 2010 that's now uh
but now you've got this DoubleDown book
about the election between Barack Obama
Mitt Romney and it's a cast of thousands
and a cast of thousands passeth oh I'm
gonna ask you about the cast of
thousands in a minute okay
but here we go it's a really
exhilarating read like it's really
exciting and for people who don't think
politics is maybe that exciting there's
probably he's surprised to find out how
much they liked this book wouldn't they
they they look like they'll laugh
they'll cry
it's a look the 2012 election was a lot
it's not much I mean you can't try to
sell the idea that it was like more
interesting or more sexy than election
the future Sarah Palin right but the
truth is it was a big election mattered
a lot for the country and and there's a
lot of drama in it a fair amount of
comedy what was the least surprising
thing that you learned in the course of
researching this book right and the
least surprising Donald Trump has a high
opinion of himself what you just told me
asked for the least surprising thing
Donald Trump has a high opinion of
himself but game change was made into an
HBO film it was fantastic Oh incredible
yeah and they had this amazing cast
there did Ed Harris John McCain John
because John McCann Julianne Moore has
Sarah Palin as Sarah Palin Woody
Harrelson has Steve Schmidt and I
understand that there may be
coming up about double down it is the
case that HBO has optioned the book and
we're really hopeful we have an
incredibly great experience working with
them on the last one
Danny strong the screenwriter Jay Roach
the director they did an incredible job
adapting it and as you said the cast was
fantastic we won a lot of awards and it
was a totally a lot of writers who have
written books you know have bad
experiences in Hollywood where they say
you know they mangled my work and blah
blah blah we had the absolute opposite
experience we were we loved working with
those guys they were great partners HBO
was fantastic and they made a great
movie so they've optioned it and we're
really hopeful that you know when they
get a chance to read it which they're
just starting to do right now that
they'll see a movie in it and that we'll
get to do another one I would love to be
able to help in any way that I can but
okay you do have to I'm gonna give you
like two I want to hear each character
Joe you have to choose between one of
the two okay playing Mitt Romney yeah do
we want to try to focus on his sort of
looks and aesthetics and go with like a
George Clooney type a very handsome man
yeah or go for the like personality and
do like a Nordstrom mannequin it's been
hard hitting us but I'm gonna split the
difference to choose Jon Hamm what I'm
sorry I said between one of the two I
chose option see you saying job part
partner partner sir mannequin parts or
excluding I'm kidding John I'm kidding
I'm kidding
don't know I look I like the non
mannequin option so I like you know Jim
Mitt Romney's and is is ace more soulful
man than most people know if they read
the book they'll see that's true okay
what's next Obama okay Chris Rock or
Jaden Smith think about the demographics
that are gonna be watching this film
well if we decide to make a comedy I'm
just directing man that's what I'm
saying I said we decide to go in a more
kind of Goldfinger in a gold more
awesome power Z direction I'm for the
Chris Rock thing though I'll tell you
what if you're trying to stick to
reality then Jimmy Smits I'll tell you
my actual you know Will Smith has said
that he wants to play a
and so I'm kind of excited about the
possibility that you might even make it
him or the other guy who I love for this
is Giancarlo Esposito from Breaking Bad
though he's got on like a whole Barack
Obama thing going on Hillary Clinton Amy
Poehler or Bill Clinton and Dre
Oh bill fun new track yeah just to see
that yes yes that would be box office
all right and what about you because you
had a cameo in game Jane I played myself
who do you want to play in double denim
I actually actually think I would make a
pretty good Newt Gingrich yeah
your furtive in the book is the angry
teddy bear so I kind of think of like I
like to think of myself as an excellent
dispute like to think of myself in that
same way